here you see an incredible new robot
that learned to explore stand up and
even handle packages and more now wait a
second what you see here should be
impossible why is that why is this
impossible dear fellow Scholars this is
two minute papers with Dr car well to
understand what is going on here let's
look into the popular large language
models first you see when training a
large language model to understand
English and be a good assistant we can
give it tons and tons of data from the
internet to learn on for instance the
early gpt2 read Amazon reviews and
learned to write new ones this was
possible because tons and tons of
training data was available however this
should be impossible for a real robot in
the real world why is that well have a
look at this page paper where scientists
at Nvidia tried to teach a software
agent to run and it kind of learned to
run okay but after quite a bit of
training at first it looked like this
now letting a robot lose in a lab while
flailing around would not work too well
because it would injure itself and its
environment before any meaningful
learning could happen so in software
there is plenty of training data to
learn from but for robotics there is no
data none or even if there is there is
just not enough to learn anything so how
can we solve this well the solution is
my favorite which is learning inside a
simulation letting the robot play around
in a video game here they are doing
reinforcement learning which means truly
playing a video game here you do
something something and if you do well
you get a score a reward if you don't do
so well you get nothing or a negative
score now we also need a little magic
sauce here to make sure that the robot
is curious and wants to explore and
understand the world around it normally
that is not that difficult for instance
deep Minds agents can play video games
as they are yearning for a high score so
they will go around and explore however
ha there is a huge problem a TV problem
yes you heard it right the AI has a TV
problem agents like these can encounter
a TV in a virtual world and then this
happens yes they get addicted to it and
they never want to leave now that is
real humanlike Behavior if I've ever
seen one this happens because the agent
is getting new information all the time
and it's much more interesting than
these otherwise boring levels so how did
they make this little robot curious well
by engineering the rewards of the game
in a way that for instance if the angle
or the velocity of the door changes it
gets a reward thus look it starts
experimenting with it now new task if we
wish to get it to move boxes around to
where they belong we can craft a reward
involving the velocity of the box and
the distance from the container now hold
on to your papers fellow Scholars
because this is the moment of truth
let's jump from the video game world
into the real world and see how this
little robot fares and who look at that
it can navigate around in the real world
competently and it can even stand up it
now now opens those doors and can handle
packages well as you see it handles them
at least as gently as some of the
delivery services out there another
humanlike trait perfect now Jokes Aside
by further tailoring these reward
functions I would imagine that it could
be much gentler with those packages and
even doors just one more paper down the
line and also Bravo what has been
achieved here here is extremely hard why
well because we cannot just make a
simpler video game for this robot to
learn on it has to be good enough to
even work in the real world after all
and if the knowledge from here does not
translate properly to here things can
break really quickly this was an amazing
feat and just imagine that now we have
better and better tools to create
Virtual Worlds a lot of our episodes are
on new papers that improve these
potential simulation environments and
every single one of those could be one
step closer for us to have these little
AIS train in these Virtual Worlds and
then come out into the real world help
us out and do all this safely for
instance these little robots could help
us with last mile delivery the idea
behind this paper could also help us
create better self-driving cars that can
safely train in an environment where we
can make crazy hard levels for it and
with a powerful computer have it train
for years and years in computer
simulation time not in real time and
then come out as a safe and competent AI
agent what a time to be alive and this
is not science fiction not at all in an
earlier paper we saw nvidia's AI train
for 33 years in simulation time time to
play in Minecraft and boy did it learn a
great deal in there now this new work of
course does not come without limitations
hand engineering reward functions is a
bit of a limitation here which means
that we have to write these rewards
ourselves so if we need it to perform a
new task it needs a new reward function
for that limiting the generality of the
agent an earlier paper we talked about
here could potentially remedy that as it
is about teaching these AI agents to
find out what a good score would be
experiment tracking model evaluation and
production monitoring for your deep
learning projects and llm apps this is
what weights and biases does and it is
the best everyone is using it try it out
now at wb. me/ papers or click the link
in the description below